and finally new rule if the new normal
is a president who has bragged about
sexual assault and walking in on naked
teenage beauty pageant contestants and
who has spoken lustfully about his own
daughter and once said of a fifth grader
I'm going to date her in ten years tell
me again why someone like Eliot Spitzer
is so terrible Eliot Spitzer who you may
recall had to go away after a hooker
scandal because when a hooker blows a
politician it puts a lobbyist out of
work but this double standard has got to
stop
we're all the Democrats horndogs have to
go live on a farm but the Republican
Hound is allowed up on the furniture in
the Oval Office so Smith sir wanted a
Busta nut so what he also wanted to bust
bankers and insider traders and did if
he were if he were a Republican today
what he did could totally be spun dating
coal girls please he was providing
struggling Millennials with a living
wage he wasn't cheating he was having
alternatives
Republicans is so much more practical
about this stuff they think Trump's
flaws come with the territory when you
hire an alpha male Trump does things
which appalled people but they also
admire the balls of it
even after [ __ ] gate he's attitude was
still defiant yeah I say hello to people
by grabbing their [ __ ] what about it
hi John Trump that's a nice firm snatch
you got there I mean compared to that
Spitzer is a choirboy
Andrea pet rehabilitating him would send
the message the Democrats are serious
about what is important and about
winning and in fact actually a guy whose
big crime is that he got a hooker
doesn't even send that message enough
which is why we need this guy yeah
Anthony Weiner yes another Jew who likes
to pork hey you want to win do you want
to go home let the chicken dinner or
what falls on telling you we need balls
and I'm sorry that the good ones are
usually a little too full of come but
they are we need our loudmouth kick-ass
New Yorker who's up all night on social
media hey you know what at least when
Weiner is playing with his phone at 3:00
a.m. he's looking for love Trump is
starting a Twitter war with the lands in
cattle
[Applause]
let's not forget that Wiener bought like
a pitbull for liberal causes and could
have been the voice of the party if not
for a mistake he made one time okay -
John three what does it matter how many
time oh [ __ ] he did it again okay
alright alright and totally can do it
[Applause]
you know what that same primal force is
why he was such a badass congressman we
don't have the luxury anymore to mess
around with milquetoast democratic
politicians who don't move people
ken Kane is a nice guy but he's the kind
of boring beta male that's made the
Democrats the designated driver party as
ridiculous as Trump is he does come off
as an alpha that's why he paints his
face the color of a baboon's ass
[Applause]
it shows dominant so if Trump if Trump
is indeed the new normal if it's now
perfectly fine for the American
president to be built causally with a
super PAC then Democrats have to go all
out too and that means Spitzer and that
means Weiner and by the way next time he
runs the more Anthony Weiner
he's Carlos danger [ __ ] yeah oh that kid
Carlos danger
a Latino Jew and rested and fully erect
a tall tongue and restoring Weiner
I mean danger that would send the
message
although wait although maybe there's
still someone even worse and by worse I
mean better John Edwards that's right
John I
yes I know left a sick wife to have an
affair with Peter Frampton and that was
wrong that was wrong but Edwards also is
the one who made health care the issue
it became for the Democrats in 2008 so
yes what he did was horrible but the
heart wants what it wants and what the
heart wants it apparently was Peter
friend I still don't get that and yes
the whole thing was disgusting but so is
openly humiliating your first wife the
mother of your children while you
romance your future second wife in
public but again Trump supporters just
make a different calculation they say no
I don't like cheating and [ __ ] grabbing
but hey this ain't a friendly fight this
is a battle for the soul of the country
and it is and since it is Democrats
should be allowed to put our alpha pervs
back on the board
especially since the Democratic Party
has a proud tradition of excellent horny
presidents fer JFK LBJ and of course how
about a bj